[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE TAPPER: Thanks so much.
It's so great to be here.
I really appreciate it.
Just first of all,
I should tell you
I wrote the book on Google Docs.
I don't know if that
means anything--
if that means anything to you.
But the idea that I could
bring my computer or not bring
my computer, and just wherever
I was-- at work or on the road--
I could write and pick
up where I left off,
not have to worry
about it saving
since it saves automatically--
it's a great product
and it really
helped me write the book.
So I'll just talk a
little bit about the book.
And then, I'll take
your questions.
I guess, when I think
of "The Hellfire Club,"
I think of it on
three basic levels.
One of them is this--
I tried to write a thriller,
what I thought would be fun.
It takes place in 1954.
A World War II hero
turned academic
named Charlie Marder
and his wife, Margaret,
who is a zoologist,
moved to Washington DC.
He gets appointed to
a congressional seat.
And immediately, they become
ensnared in a grand conspiracy
with secret societies
and all sorts of factions
competing against each other.
One of the things that
I thought would be fun--
and I hope is fun for readers--
is I have actual
people from that time--
like Joe McCarthy, and Roy Cohn,
and John and Robert Kennedy,
and Eisenhower, and
others-- interacting
with my fictitious characters,
which I thought would be fun.
People ask me all the
time, why the 1950s?
And I think of the 1950s as
a time that, on its veneer--
especially, if
you're a white male--
it is an idyllic period.
In our popular culture,
we think of "Happy Days"
or "American Graffiti."
We think of the '50s
as a pleasant time.
But actually, it was
a time of real menace.
You had actual communists
infiltrating the government.
You had McCarthyism
and the Red Scare.
You had the atomic race.
In March, 1954, Puerto
Rican separatists burst
into the capitol
and shoot it up,
and shoot five
members of the House.
There are the bizarre
comic book hearings,
where the US Senate is
blaming juvenile delinquency
on comic books.
Any of you who
collect comic books--
and I'm guessing at Google,
it's probably a few--
the little Comics
Code Authority--
the little tag on the front
page of the comic books--
is a remnant of
that ridiculous era.
So I thought it would be fun.
I thought it would be just an
exciting time to write about.
That's one level I
think about the book.
Another level I think about
the book is Charlie Marder--
one of the two main characters--
comes to Washington to do good.
And one of the first
things he tries to do
is to stop a company-- a
rubber and tire company that
made bad gas masks
during World War II--
stop them from getting
any federal money.
And he finds out that
in order to do good,
he needs to make compromises.
And this is something that I've
just noticed in Washington DC,
having lived there
now, basically,
since the end of 1992--
which is really good people--
Democrats, and Republicans,
and Independents--
come to town to do good things.
They want to do good.
And a lot of them get trapped
in a cycle of compromise,
where they dip one foot into
the swamp and another foot
into the swamp.
And the next thing they know,
they're up to their neck
in swamp and they don't
know how to get out.
So that was another
thing I wanted
to try to capture
in the book, is just
the idea of why it happens--
that so many good people
that you believe in,
you look up and 10
years later, and you're
like, whatever happened to her
or whatever happened to him?
I used to think that that
person was pretty cool,
and now they're not.
Which is not to say
that there aren't still
a lot of really good
people in Congress.
There are.
The heroes of the
book are politicians
and the villains of the
book are politicians,
so they're both covered.
And then, the last
thing is, in addition
to the swamp, the thing
that I think is resonant
for a lot of readers is--
and this was--
I started writing
this book years ago.
And if you set a book
in 1954, and you're
going to have people--
characters-- interacting with
real people from the era,
obviously Roy Cohn
and Joe McCarthy
are going to be obvious people
you're going to seize upon.
I did not know at the time
that Roy Cohn's protégé,
Donald Trump, was going to be
president of the United States
by the time the book came out.
But it turns out there is this
connective tissue that Senator
McCarthy's protégé was Roy
Cohn, and Roy Cohn's protégé was
Donald Trump.
That's nothing I invented.
It just is a reality.
And so diving into the 1950s
and reading about the time
of McCarthyism-- and
I don't want to--
Donald Trump and Joe McCarthy
are not the same person,
and Trumpism and McCarthyism
are not the same thing.
But the occurrence of a major
political figure using lying,
and smearing, and
indecency as his method
of art in his political
warfare has happened before.
And reading about people
and how political figures
acted or didn't act at the
time was very instructive.
So some of the book--
not a lot of it--
I might have played
up a little bit,
or I did play up a little
bit, because of the era
that we're in.
But the rhyming-- you
know, they say, history
doesn't repeat
itself, but it rhymes.
And the rhyming
was already there,
and so there is some of that.
I thought I'd read one
really quick scene to you.
I want to apologize
ahead of time--
especially to a Boston crowd--
because I am going to do
Robert Kennedy's voice.
And I want you to know that I
don't think I do it very well,
but I can't not do it.
One of the thrills about writing
this book was the research.
I know I'm in a room full of
people who like to do research.
And last year, I did an event
for the 100th anniversary
of the birth of John F. Kennedy.
And I met Kathleen
Kennedy Townsend,
who is Robert
Kennedy's oldest child.
And I was doing-- you know, I
was in the thick of research.
And actually, I had
read in several books
that her godfather was Joe
McCarthy, because the Kennedys
and Joe McCarthy
were very close.
So I fact checked it with her.
And she said, no,
it wasn't true,
but they were very close--
the families were very close.
And I asked her why, because Joe
McCarthy was a horrible person.
And she said it was very tribal
because they were all Irish,
and the '40s and
the '50s were still
a period where the Irish
were looked down upon.
And no matter how much
the Kennedys achieved,
the Boston Brahmins still
looked down their noses
at the Kennedys.
And so they bonded that way.
Then another time,
I was reading--
when I was doing
research for the book--
I was reading a Ted Sorensen
biography of John F. Kennedy.
And Sorensen kept referring
to Robert Kennedy as Bob--
Bob Kennedy-- which I had
never heard before in my life,
and I'm something of
a student of history.
And so I emailed Kathleen
Kennedy Townsend,
did people call your dad Bob,
because I'm reading this book?
And she said, yeah, that's
what they called him.
So I have a character in the
book correcting somebody.
Nobody calls him Bobby.
Anybody who knows
him calls him Bob.
Now, I told this anecdote
at a publishing event
about a year ago, forgetting
that one of Robert Kennedy's
other kids was in the audience.
He had, like, 100.
And this one was Kerry
Kennedy Cuomo, I think.
I was doing a presentation
for "The Hellfire Club."
She was doing a
presentation for a book that
was commemorating the 50th
anniversary of her father's
assassination.
And she-- after I told that
story about Bob and Robert
and Bobby--
she went on stage
and corrected me.
She said, it wasn't
necessarily true.
People called him Bob.
Some people called him Bobby.
Some people called him senator.
And I went up to her
afterwards and I said,
you know, your oldest
sister is the one
who told me the Bob thing.
And I'm an oldest
child in my family.
And I know who has the
most credible information
in any family, and that
is the oldest child.
We are the keepers of history.
So anyway, I took
it as a good sign
that Kathleen Kennedy Townsend's
daughter came to one of my book
events in Washington DC.
I took it as
official recognition
that I had it right.
The oldest child is correct.
So this is just a quick
scene just to give you
a taste of the
book, where Charlie
is at a fancy party at the
Mayflower Hotel in Washington
being thrown by Conrad Hilton
after Congress passed a bill
to let cheap Mexican
labor come over the border
more easily, which they actually
did that actual day-- or that
actual week.
And Charlie goes,
and he and Roy Cohn
start getting into a fight--
an argument.
Roy Cohn is such a fun character
to write because you could just
make him be really
smart and just the worst
person in the world, except
for possibly Joe McCarthy.
So anyway, at this
point, Robert Kennedy--
Bob Kennedy-- walks in and tries
to settle the two because they
seem to be squaring off.
And again, I apologize
for my Kennedy accent.
""Evening Roy,' Bob Kennedy
said, approaching them.
Recognizing Charlie,
he said, 'Congressman.'
'Charlie Marder,' Charlie said,
not sure if Kennedy remembered
his name.
In Washington,
Charlie had noticed
people tended to avoid names
in case they got them wrong.
They tended to say,
nice to see you,
instead of nice to meet you, in
case they had met you before.
New social rules
for an egoistic town
where every monument
and street was
named for their predecessors.
'Right, of course,'
said Kennedy.
'We met you and your lovely
wife at Martin's Tavern.
I just heard you're working with
Estes on the upcoming juvenile
delinquency hearings.'
Cohn choked on his drink.
It turned out he was laughing.
'You're part of those bullshit
comic book hearings,' he
guffawed dramatically.
Kennedy grinned and looked
at Charlie apologetically.
Charlie was not
particularly amused.
He'd had enough of Cohn's
abrasive company by now.
'You were asking me about the
commie symps in this room,
congressman,' Cohn said.
'Well, they worry me more
than Wonder Woman does.'
He took another
swig of his drink
and stared out the window.
'But none of them concern me as
much as the commie symps over
there in that big white
building,' motioning with his
chin toward the White House.
'What must the world look
like from that address?
It must look upside down.
Goddamn Ike protects the
commies and screws with Senator
McCarthy.'
Cohn looked at Kennedy.
'He's terrified Joe will
run for president, you know.
Joe could beat him, too.'
'Joe McCarthy could beat
President Eisenhower?' asked
Charlie incredulously. 'Beat
the smartest general we've had
since Sherman?'
'Smart?' said Cohn.
'MacArthur called Ike the
best clerk he ever had.'
'And Ike said he studied
drama under General MacArthur
for four years.'
Kennedy chuckled.
'Now, gentlemen.
MacArthur-- MacArthur,'
said Charlie sarcastically,
pretending to search the skies
for a reminder of the general,
so ignominiously fired by
Truman three years earlier.
'The name rings a bell.'
'MacArthur's a great man,
a patriot,' said Cohn.
'I'm sure you have a medal of
honor under your shirt there?'
'No,' said Charlie,
'just some shrapnel.'
He finished the
rest of his drink.
'Nothing like your paper cuts
from the Battle of Torts 101.'
An awkward silence
hung like a noose.
Charlie had surprised even
himself with that one.
Liquid courage, he supposed.
Kennedy tried to
break the tension.
'Why do you think Joe would
be a good president, Roy?'
'If Joe were
president,' Cohn said,
'the first thing he would do
would be to end the Cold War.
He'd pick up the phone and
call Joe Stalin and say,
this is Joe McCarthy.
I'm coming over tomorrow
to talk about things.
Meet me at the Moscow
airport at 1 o'clock.
When he arrived in
Moscow, he would sit down
with Stalin in a closed room.
First, he'd tell a
couple dirty jokes.
Then, he'd look Stalin
right in the eye
and say, Joe, what do you want?
And Stalin would tell him.
They would talk man to man,
not like pansy diplomats.
They'd find out what
each of them wanted
and settle their differences.
But when Joe left,
he'd tell Stalin,
the first time I catch you
breaking this agreement,
I'll blow you and your whole
goddamn country off the map.'
Charlie turned to Kennedy.
'He can't honestly believe
this rubbish, can't he?'"
So one of the things
about that scene that I
like is the entire paragraph
where Roy Cohn is explaining
why he thinks Joe McCarthy
would be a great president
is an actual paragraph, except
it wasn't said by Roy Cohn.
It was said by Joe
McCarthy's campaign manager--
a guy named Urban Van Susteren--
who would go on to have a
daughter named Greta Van
Susteren.
And it really gets to the
fact that some of this stuff--
the truth in the book-- is
often stranger than the fiction.
That paragraph reminded
me so much of the pitch
that we would hear
on the campaign trail
about why Trump would
be a great negotiator.
He'd go into a room with Putin.
He'd do this-- blah, blah, blah.
And you know, like I said,
history doesn't repeat itself,
but it rhymes.
And I heard a lot of rhyming.
And one of the fun
things about this book--
and it's actually one of the
reasons why I included about 10
or 15 pages of endnotes
at the end of it--
is because there's so many
weird details that are real,
I wanted people to know that
I didn't make it all up.
Like, a lot of it
actually happened.
There's important
stuff, and then there's
strange little color,
like when Eisenhower--
I'm sorry, when McCarthy would
drink, which he did a lot,
he would also eat
a stick of butter.
He would just order a stick of
butter and eat it with a fork.
And I thought it was so
strange, I put it in there.
But I said, people are going
to think that, oh, it's too
weird-- that I made that up.
And then, so I put in a
whole endnote section,
which is also probably
the researcher
nerd in me showing
off a little, perhaps.
Anyway, so that's
"The Hellfire Club."
And it's doing OK.
We're going to debut on "The
New York Times" bestseller list
this Sunday at number three.
And we've been selling
a lot of books.
And I've been going
all over the country.
And it's really
great to be here.
And I'm happy to take
any questions you have.
And I recognize that
they might not all
be about the book,
which is fine.
But I do hope you
check out the book.
So thank you so much
[APPLAUSE]
So should I sit here?
OK, cool.
SPEAKER: So I'll just
kick off the conversation.
I was really interested
in your choice
to write a fiction novel at
this time in our history,
when I think a
lot of journalists
are publishing memoirs
right now, publishing
a lot of non-fiction.
And given the
parallels between what
happened in the
McCarthy era and today,
did you feel that fiction
was a really good way
to sort of explore things
more allegorically as
opposed to writing a
work of non-fiction?
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah, well,
there are a few reasons,
because we're complicated people
and we don't only do things
for one reason, right?
But one of them
was the last book
I wrote was called
"The Outpost--
An Untold Story of
American Valor."
It was a true story about one
combat outpost in Afghanistan,
and its whole 3.5 year history,
and then the deadliest battle
for the US in 2009.
And to be completely candid,
it was a very wrenching
experience, writing that book.
I did more than 200 interviews.
I traveled to Afghanistan twice.
I spent a lot of time
talking to people
who had sacrificed a great deal,
including loved ones and limbs.
And while certainly,
what I went through
was nothing compared to
what they went through,
it was very emotionally taxing.
So I was looking for a
project that would be fun.
That project was important,
but it wasn't fun.
But then, yes, you're
absolutely onto something.
I think that I was
able to make arguments
I wanted to make about, not
just about indecency and lies--
the kind that we're
experiencing now
on a daily basis from
the White House--
but also compromise,
also the importance
of standing up for
what you believe in
in an allegorical way.
I think that if I had tried
to do it in a non-fiction way,
it would not have worked.
But doing it in a way that
was combined with a thriller
and fun flight of
fancy elements--
that that might make more
sense and be more effective.
SPEAKER: Do folks in the
audience have questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my question is
about lying, actually.
And I appreciate that you--
I've noticed you call out
people you're interviewing
if they're obviously lying,
or if they're repeating lies,
or that kind of thing.
And I'm wondering if you
think, with your experience,
that we may get back
to a point where
people aren't lying as much,
or if this is sort of normal?
And I'm also
interested in sort of,
as a journalist, when you know
something is a lie, like just
how are you striking that
balance when something
is clearly a lie?
JAKE TAPPER: So
everywhere I go, everybody
wants to know whether
or not we're ever
going to go back to normal.
And I don't know.
I hope so.
I mean, right now, we're in
a period where in the last 24
hours, somebody went
on "Fox Business News,"
and attacked John McCain--
called him Songbird
John, and basically
smeared his war record.
And then, somebody
at the White House
was making fun of the
fact that he was dying.
You know, I can't
even imagine that.
I mean, I remember
covering the 2000 campaign
when John McCain got
smeared in South Carolina,
but at least that was
like shadowy groups
without ties to--
direct ties to George W. Bush
and his opponents at the time.
This is like people
just saying things.
So we're in a time of
lies and indecency.
And I see them as part and
parcel of the same thing,
because it all has to do with
we don't care about standards.
And I hope we get back to it.
I worry.
I really do.
In terms of calling out lies,
or untruths, or falsehoods,
or whatever you
want to call them,
I mean, a lie means
you know it's false
and you're saying it anyway.
And I try to be more
selective about the use of lie
versus falsehood in terms
of what I can assert.
But if President Trump
says something wrong,
and then after it's
been pointed out
that it's wrong, he continues
to say it, at that point,
I think it's a lie.
Maybe the first time, he
misunderstood or he misspoke.
And I just think we
just need to call
these things what
they are because we
can't normalize this.
We can't normalize making
fun of the disabled,
or making light of people's
drug and alcohol problems,
or the demonization
of minorities.
It's just not acceptable.
And that's not to say that
he's wrong on immigration,
or he's wrong on trade,
or he's wrong on--
I mean, those are
issues and we should
have those policy debates.
But the indecency
and the lies just--
if news anchors aren't willing
to say what they are, who is?
Right?
We're supposed to be the
arbiters of fact and truth.
And if we can't say,
that's not true,
then I don't know what
we're doing there.
AUDIENCE: You might
have heard last week
that there's a new Google
News app that was announced.
Quite a few people in
this room worked on that
and continue to work on it.
If you had a lot
of people and a lot
of resources in
terms of technology,
what would you build?
JAKE TAPPER: Oh, God.
It's such a tough-- you know,
I was talking to [? Sanders ?]
about this before, because
one of the things--
I mean, I use Google
News all the time.
I mean, all the time.
I could not do my
job without Google.
And in fact, by the
way, one of the reasons
I set my book in 1954-- not the
main reason, by any stretch,
but one of the reasons
why I set it in 1954--
is because every plot of every
movie or book that we know
and love inevitably would
become ruined if it was set now,
because it's just like,
well, why didn't you
just Google it and realize
that every city he's been to
has had a rash of
serial murders?
Why didn't you just call her?
And then, I started noticing
that a lot of movies
now, people are in the
middle of the desert
and they don't have cell
service, because cell
phones and Google ruin plots.
So anyway, I use Google News.
You know, I have to find
out more about this app.
I mean, I've heard about it,
but I've been on this book tour,
so I haven't had the
time to plunge in.
I think one of the
problems-- and I
don't know that
this is something
that you guys can come up
with or what you can solve--
but there's so much
fake news out there.
There's so many lies out there.
And it's not just by
truepundit.com or whatever.
Some of them are by Breitbart
or agenda-driven publications.
And I don't know how Facebook
or Google or anyone--
how you make a decision
about what is news
and what is not news.
But since we're
talking theoretically,
in my own perfect universe, I
would have some sort of method
to help consumers, without
any sort of political agenda
or political bias, a way
to discern what's real
and what's not.
But I don't think that
you guys can do that.
This is in a perfect world.
This is a utopian idea.
And I recognize the
slippery slope of, well,
if you say this about this
news organization, what
about this news organization?
Or if these people are purposely
wrong about this story, what
about this time that "The New
York Times," or "NBC News,"
or whatever got something
accidentally wrong, et cetera.
So I realize it's a very
difficult challenge.
And that probably didn't
answer your question.
I'll think about it more though.
AUDIENCE: That's pretty close.
JAKE TAPPER: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Let's say,
10 years from now,
you decide to write
a novel about today.
I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about what
the protagonist would
be like in your novel.
JAKE TAPPER: Well, I mean,
honestly, I don't think
that "The Hellfire Club"--
I mean, if you
read it, you'll see
that there's a lot in the
book about the choices
that people are facing
today, except it's just
framed in the 1950s.
If you read about
the 1950s, you'll
see that there were
heroes at the time.
One of my heroes-- now that I've
done research on this book--
is a woman, Margaret
Chase Smith.
She was a senator from Maine.
First woman elected to
the House and the Senate
in her own right.
In 1950, she went to
the floor of the Senate
and gave her declaration of
conscience speech, in which she
condemned McCarthyism in 1950,
when he was just starting
to become popular and powerful.
Edward R. Murrow, who
is a hero of mine,
he didn't go after
McCarthy until 1954.
And the US Senate didn't censure
him till the end of 1954.
So she was years ahead.
One of the things when you read
about that era that you see
is that there were a lot
of people who failed.
The Kennedys failed,
quite frankly,
and I'm a student
of the Kennedys.
But Robert Kennedy was the
chief democratic counsel
on the McCarthy committee.
John F. Kennedy was
pretty AWOL when
it came to condemning McCarthy.
More importantly, McCarthy's
fellow Republicans failed.
Senator Bob Taft, who ran
for president in 1952,
lost to Eisenhower-- lost
the nomination to Eisenhower.
But the Senate went
into Republican hands,
and Taft became the
majority leader.
I'm sure that Senator Taft
thought that his agenda--
his legacy would be that he's
Mr. Conservative, that he stood
up for these
conservative values,
that he represented something
important in American
foreign policy and
American domestic policy.
But at the end of the day,
he died suddenly in 1953.
And a big part of his legacy is
he didn't stand up to McCarthy.
And if I were a
member of Congress,
I would think about Bob
Taft every day of the year--
every day-- and think--
we all like to think that
our legacies are going
to be like our achievements,
but the truth of the matter
is our legacy and
how we're remembered
is often dictated
by the moral choices
that we make, or fail to make.
And so I don't think I need to
write a book about the Trump
era because I think what I've
written is resonant enough.
But you know what?
Maybe my son will
write it in 50 years,
and you can say that
it was your idea
and try to get a
share of the profits.
SPEAKER: I want to take one
of our online questions now.
This one is on immigration.
"I feel media always
tends to discuss more
about undocumented immigrants,
with whom I sympathize,
and ignore the plight
of legal immigrants
who have to get through
hellish restrictions.
Do you see a change in future
where legal immigrants would
be considered for discussion
in media and elsewhere?"
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah,
it's a great question.
I mean, I think the reason
that the media focuses
on illegal immigrants, or
undocumented immigrants,
is because they are the ones
that are being threatened-- you
know, rounded up in ICE
raids, and being threatened
with expulsion, et cetera.
We do have legal
immigrants on our shows
all the time, not because
they're legal immigrants,
but because they just happen
to be incredibly talented
and it turns out they're
legal immigrants-- like Ana
Navarro, who is from
Nicaragua, is a good example.
But I think the
debate is largely
about illegal immigration.
Although the immigration
bill that Cotton and Perdue
introduced-- which would have a
big effect on legal immigration
if that bill ever were to
become seriously considered,
which I don't think
it would as of now,
not with this Senate and the
Democrats able to block it--
I think there would be a lot
more discussion and debate
about legal immigration.
Unfortunately, we
have to make choices.
And the people in the media
tend to go to the bigger story
and can't always
focus on everything.
AUDIENCE: So sort of related to
your comments about fake news,
a lot of people often
just receive news
from a single source
or from their friends,
which may not be fake.
It might be good news, but
it might also be consistently
from one point of view.
Do you have any
suggestions for how
people could be broken out
of their ideological echo
chambers?
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah,
and I'm a huge--
I follow more than--
not to bring up a
competitor-- but I
follow more than 5,000
people on Twitter.
And one of the great
things about it
is I try to get as many
divergent viewpoints as
possible.
And I completely agree with--
look, I was the kid in
high school and college
that would go to the library.
And I would read "The
Nation," and then I
would read the
"National Review."
I was always trying to get news
from different perspectives.
And my friends in DC--
some of them are very,
very liberal, some of them
are very, very conservative.
And as somebody who is generally
fairly politically agnostic
in my personal views, which
is actually kind of a relief,
it's a pleasure for me
to try to open my eyes
and see how the world
looks to everyone.
Now, sometimes, the world looks
to some people rooted like it's
not actually this world.
It's actually some
other world where
there's a whole other set
of facts, that on this world
are actually not true.
So I tend to avoid those
websites and those channels.
But I think that it's-- and I'm
giving a commencement address
at UMass Amherst later today.
And one of the things
I'm going to be saying
is expose yourself to as
many different points of view
as possible because that's
how you enrich your knowledge.
And not just in terms of
liberal versus conservative,
but also in terms of
military versus nonmilitary,
or what does the world
look like from Yemen,
what does the world look
like from the point of view
of somebody who is deeply
religious-- whether Baptist,
or Muslim, or Jewish.
I mean, to expose yourself to
all different points of view,
I think, is so important.
It's a big part of what
you guys do, I know.
And it's a big part
of what I do too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for being
here with us this morning.
We appreciate you
spending some time.
I do have a question, but I
just want to get everything
on the table first.
JAKE TAPPER: Uh oh.
AUDIENCE: --which is to say that
we know you're an Eagles fan.
JAKE TAPPER: I'm sorry.
I knew it was going to come up.
Isn't it enough, the Celtics?
That's not enough?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we're
happy with the Celtics.
And I'm going to be mature
and say congratulations.
JAKE TAPPER: Well,
congratulations to you.
You guys almost swept us.
I mean, you know,
that's painful for me.
I mean, I grew up in the
'80s when you guys had
the master team of Larry Bird.
So I'm sorry.
Look, we don't win a
lot of championships.
AUDIENCE: And we're spoiled.
I get it.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah, how
many rings do you need,
for God's sake?
AUDIENCE: No, they earned it.
JAKE TAPPER: I'm sorry, I
got a little carried away
during football season.
I admit it.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: I won't bring
up the disparaging remarks
about the Patriots.
JAKE TAPPER: Please don't,
because I actually heard
from Robert Kraft about them.
So I get it.
I got a little heated.
I got a little excited.
You know, I don't know what
it is about Philadelphia--
because Boston people don't
seem to have this issue--
but we have chips
on our shoulder.
And we feel like
we're underdogs, even
compared to Boston,
even though we're
a bigger city than Boston.
So I don't understand
it, but you guys
seem to handle your non-New
York, LA status much better
than we do.
I can't explain it.
AUDIENCE: Well, it was a
little different before 2004.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But my question is--
so you talked a
little bit about how
the DC you write
about in the book
is maybe not that different
than the DC we see today.
And I think a lot
of us, regardless
of political leaning,
feel pretty fed up,
and in some ways, at a little
bit of a loss about what to do.
And we hear a lot
of talk about, well,
if you really want to
make a difference, run
for local office.
And that makes sense.
And some people are in
a position to do that,
and many of us maybe are not.
So I guess I'm wondering
if you have one or two
pieces of advice-- sort
of the first things you'd
say to an everyday
engaged citizen about what
steps to take.
JAKE TAPPER: Wow, OK.
So that's a really
good question.
The truth of the matter is, is
that the best thing you can do
is support candidates
that you believe in.
And if it's local candidates,
then you can knock on doors
and make phone calls.
And if it's candidates in other
states, you can send money.
Or also there are ways to
either travel to knock on doors
or make phone calls, also.
Although, you know, generally
those kinds of things
are better coming from in state.
But, you know, I
think that Washington
is better in some ways
than it was in the 1950s.
Because of the post-Watergate
reforms, we know more.
Believe it or not, the
media is much better now
than the media was in the 1950s.
The media covered up all sorts
of stuff for people in power.
And we know things.
Somebody asked me the
other day about how
would a journalist in the
1950s cover Scott Pruitt.
We wouldn't even know
about Scott Pruitt.
We wouldn't know
any of that stuff.
And there wouldn't be reporters
covering it as aggressively.
If you go back and
read newspapers from
the '50s-- and I
did for this book--
there was a lot of great
journalism being done,
but it is much more
aggressive today.
So things, I think, are
better in many ways.
There's a lot more money today.
And that makes it worse.
But on balance, I would say
we're probably a little better
off.
But I honestly think that the
best thing that people can do
is find candidates
who you believe in.
And also, I don't think--
I mean, if you're
a Democrat, great.
If you're a Republican, great.
But I think that people should
scratch beneath the surface
beyond just party labels.
It's important that there be
reformers in both parties.
It's important that
there be people
in both parties who are willing
to stand up for certain values.
There's a guy named--
well, I probably shouldn't
name individual politicians,
but let me just say that there
are Democrats and Republicans
in Washington who I
see legitimately raging
against the machine and
really actually trying
to do good and stand
up for what is right.
And I think it's important
to have both parties have
that kind of pressure.
So if you are not necessarily
the most partisan person
in the world, I would argue,
look at the other party
and see if there are
people from the other party
that you can support
in the primary.
So even if-- and also
there are certain districts
that are never going
to elect a Democrat
and certain districts
that are never
going to elect a Republican.
There's nothing wrong
with, theoretically,
finding the best person from
the party that's definitely
going to win and
supporting that party
and supporting that person,
even if you disagree
with them on issue x, y, and z.
That's just my view.
Look, it's easy for me to say.
I don't give money to anybody
because I'm a journalist.
But I mean, I just think
that a lot of times
I don't look at the world and--
people who live in Washington
and political journalists
see that partisanship
is important
and the parties are different.
And I'm not disputing
any of that,
but there are also other
ways to split up the town.
And one of them is people
who want to reform it
and people who like how
it is, because the status
quo is fine with them.
Can I say one other thing
about your question?
Which is, it is tougher to
challenge yourself and get out
of your ideological--
not you-- but get out
of one's ideological bubble.
Right now, we are in a
period where people go home
and they put on their team
jerseys and watch cable news.
And they want to have
their beliefs reaffirmed.
And I see things
on both of our--
look, I'm biased
because I'm with CNN,
but I see things on
both channels that
are our main competitors,
Fox and MS, that I think,
that's really not
telling the whole story.
Sometimes I watch MSNBC
or see something on MSNBC
and I think, boy,
they make it sound
like President Trump's
about to be arrested
in like the next five minutes.
And then on Fox,
there's no Russian--
what Russian investigation?
So I mean, I think breaking
free of those bubbles
is very important, even though
it's more difficult to do that.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks for being here.
So I wanted to talk a little bit
about the kind of terminology
that we use.
Like, for instance,
I'm a big fan
of liberal democratic
values, but more so
in the Thomas Jefferson sense
than the Elizabeth Warren
sense.
So as far as lower case
liberal democratic principles,
what do you see the media's
role as in promoting, defending,
championing those
values, or being
neutral about them relative
to maybe illiberal values
or undemocratic?
JAKE TAPPER: Well,
why don't you tell us?
How would you define lowercase
l liberal and lowercase d
democratic values?
How would you?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I'll borrow the
definition from Yascha Mounk,
who was here a couple months
ago giving a similar talk.
Which is, liberalism in the
sense of civil liberties,
standing up for the voice and
the rights of minority groups
or marginalized
groups in society,
and democracy being the will
of the people translated
through some process or
representation in government.
And these can be at odds, right?
But for instance, if the
majority of the people
decide that, yes, we need
to strip this minority
group of certain rights
or certain voting
rights or their voice,
there's some tension there.
But together, it seems like
that's the magical package,
that when America
throughout history
is operating at its best, we
find a good balance of that.
But at times, we get off balance
and off kilter about that.
So I'm curious about those
combined values which
don't always
naturally go together,
do you see the media as having
a role with those values
and promoting them or being
more neutral about them,
like the media ideally should
be neutral about partisan
political policy issues?
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah, that's
a challenging question.
I mean, I think,
first of all, one
of the things that's at
the heart of your question
is the idea that we should
be covering individual issues
on their merits and not--
without the partisan divide
necessarily as the only prism
through which we see.
I mean, so for
instance, if we're
talking about NSA
wiretapping, or drone strikes,
or whatever, we
should just be talking
about that in terms
of the efficacy
and the morality of it.
And I think the
best way we can do
that is by having intellectually
honest guests to discuss them.
And sometimes it's, in
Washington, not always
the easiest thing
in the world to do,
because people tend to see
things through partisan lenses.
But for instance, Senator
Chris Murphy of Connecticut,
who is a pretty
partisan Democrat,
but he was very critical
of the Obama administration
for its role in--
this is not a domestic
issue, but for its role
in the war in Yemen, the
proxy war between Saudi Arabia
and Iran that's going
on in Yemen right now.
And having him on-- whenever
there's somebody who is just
refreshingly candid, and honest,
and open about a debate about
a principle--
Senator Tim Kaine
was like that when
it came to the authorization
for use of military force.
I think it's just important
to run to those voices
so that people can
see these issues
through non-partisan lenses.
In terms of the
positions we take,
I don't know that it's my job
to say the United States should
not be doing this.
The United States should
not be doing that.
I think that there are
certain lines we can draw,
but really it's much
more my job to have
on people to have
discussions about these
and to make sure that these
discussions are rooted in facts
and truth, and where people
can make their arguments one
way or the other.
I don't necessarily--
unless it's stark,
I don't think it helps
the viewer for me to say,
well, this is unconstitutional.
That's not for me to say if
there's a debate about it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JAKE TAPPER: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
So getting back to the parallels
between Trump and McCarthy,
McCarthy eventually reached
a point where he went too far
and the party abandoned
him and he was censured.
Can you foresee any
sort of similar scenario
where something similar
happens with Trump,
or do you think it's as
straightforward as, as long
as the base supports
him the Republican
Party is going to fall in line?
JAKE TAPPER: It's a
lot more complicated
than that, because first of
all, he's the president and not
a Wisconsin senator.
Second of all,
he's signing bills
that the Republicans
want him to sign,
and he's doing things that
some of them, I think,
have his support.
If he succeeds to
any degree in North
Korea and the Korean peninsula,
that will be a great thing.
But in terms of just the decency
and the lies, I don't know.
And if I've learned
anything about predictions
with Donald Trump, it's
don't make predictions
about Donald Trump.
But I do wonder,
if he were to fire
Mueller, what would happen?
Would that be a bridge too far?
I feel as though Speaker
Ryan and Leader McConnell
have made it clear,
privately and publicly,
that they don't think
that should happen.
I don't know what they
are willing to tolerate.
And I don't know what
Republican members of Congress
are willing to tolerate.
Having lived through and
covered the Clinton years,
I find it unimaginable.
I mean, if President--
I guess he couldn't have
fired Ken Starr because there
was an independent
counsel law at the time,
but behavior is being
tolerated now by Republicans
that they never would
have tolerated before.
And in fact, every
day it's just a
here's what Rudy
Giuliani says now
and here's what he
said 20 years ago,
and it was the same
exact situation
except it was Bill Clinton.
Here's what Mike Pence
says now, except here's
what he said two years ago
when it was Hillary Clinton.
So the hypocrisy doesn't
seem to bother people
very much anymore.
I don't know.
I don't know how
much farther we're
going to be tested as a
nation, in terms of the checks
and balances.
So far everything, the American
institutions and the separation
of powers are still there.
Mueller is still investigating.
I don't know.
If I had to pick
a bridge too far,
it would be possibly
firing Mueller,
but I honestly don't know.
And if you go back and look at--
I mean, the Senate tolerated
a lot from Joe McCarthy.
A lot.
And you go back, he smeared
senators in the late '40s.
I mean, there's
this bizarre-- it's
mentioned briefly in the book.
There's this bizarre period in
American history, where there
was a massacre committed by
Nazis towards the end of World
War II.
And then a lot of those
Nazis were captured,
and they went to a prisoner
of war camp in New Jersey.
And interrogators, American
military interrogators,
were accused of being
too tough on these Nazis.
They weren't torturing
them, but they were
accused of mistreating them.
And at the time
in the late '40s,
there was a big movement by
German Americans to whitewash
what had happened
in World War II.
And McCarthy was part of that.
And he took over this committee
he wasn't even a member of,
that was investigating
the alleged mistreatment
of these Nazis, and basically
smeared the chairman, who
ended up retiring.
And I have a character in the
book saying something like,
"Oh, I thought we'd all come
to our conclusions about Nazis
already," which was something
else that I added post-2016.
So my only point is, the
US Senate tolerated a lot.
He smeared war heroes.
He smeared US senators.
It was only after the
Army-McCarthy hearings
and some violation of Senate
rules that they took him on.
But a lot of people had
been ruined by then.
AUDIENCE: Brief
follow up on that.
Do you think it was
more-- so after he
went after the
army, do you think
it was the people
got tired of him,
the politicians followed suit?
Or do you think
it was politicians
displaying some leadership?
JAKE TAPPER: One of the
reasons the book is set in 1954
is because he began that year
at the height of his power.
There's a book by David Nichols
called "Ike Versus McCarthy"
that I used as a basis
for some of the plot
in the book, which is the
idea that Eisenhower was
the whole time setting a plot,
setting a trap for McCarthy,
and the Army-McCarthy
hearings were part of that.
Ultimately, I think
McCarthy gave them
an opening in the
Army-McCarthy hearings,
and the US Senate took it.
But like I said, that
they tolerated a lot.
George Marshall is a
hero of World War II.
He's a hero of the post-war.
And Joe McCarthy smeared him.
He wrote a book about
him, just attacking him.
And there was a
time in 1952, when
Eisenhower, who was so
sick of McCarthy doing this
to his friend and
mentor George Marshall,
that Eisenhower was going
to say something about it
during a campaign
appearance in Wisconsin.
And McCarthy was
going to be onstage.
And at the last minute,
the governor of Wisconsin
heard about it and convinced
Eisenhower to take it out
of his speech.
And it was something
he regretted
for the rest of his life.
Although we have to give him
credit for going to Wisconsin,
I guess.
Little Hillary Clinton
joke there, sorry.
But in any case,
my only point is,
people are willing
to put up with a lot
until all of a
sudden they're not.
I don't know where
this US Congress is.
SPEAKER: So I had a question
about the echoes of gun
violence that both pervade your
book and what's going on today.
It really struck me
as reading the book,
this violence goes back all
the way through our history.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Just the anecdotes
about William Taulbee
earlier in the book.
JAKE TAPPER: That's
a congressman
who killed a reporter.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you think about
that in the context.
JAKE TAPPER: In Congress.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
JAKE TAPPER: And the bloodstains
are still on the stairs.
That's true.
Yeah, once again,
look to the endnotes.
Sorry.
SPEAKER: And now here we are
today, and a couple of months
ago you moderated the
town hall at Parkland.
And I know you said it was one
of the hardest things you ever
did.
And I just wonder,
what can we do,
where do we go from here,
and your thoughts on that?
[SIGHS]
JAKE TAPPER: OK.
It was challenging just because
the emotions in the room
were just so raw.
You know, their daughters, and
sons, and brothers, and friends
had been murdered
one week before,
and everybody was so raw.
And it was an opportunity
to facilitate them to allow
them to speak truth to power.
But it was difficult
just emotionally.
I mean, again, much more
so for them than for me,
but it was just tough to do,
to be around all that pain
and heartache.
I don't know what the solution
is to gun violence in America.
I recognize that it's
a complicated problem,
and it's probably a
lot more complicated
than policymakers on either
side, on the extremes,
want to make it seem.
There is no way that
the US Senate, even
under Democratic control,
would be willing to ban
so-called "assault weapons."
They won't.
If the Democrats want
to control the Senate,
they need to have
Democrats in there
from places like West
Virginia and Montana
who won't vote for those things.
That said, there are a lot
of commonsense measures
that it would seem, you would
think, would be able to get
support, ones that the president
has expressed support for.
And yet, when the cameras
are off, not so much.
I don't have a solution.
And I wish I did.
Obviously, the
biggest intersection,
it seems to me, where
there should be action
is in the nexus between people
with violent emotional problems
and their ability to get guns.
And it seems to me that
the temporary restraining
order that allows family
members to say to a judge
or to a police officer, we're
worried about this person,
and we think that they have
guns, and we're concerned,
and they petition the court,
that that should be something.
California
experimented with that
or passed something like
that after the San--
Santa Barbara or San Bernardino?
SPEAKER: San Bernardino.
JAKE TAPPER: San Berna--
no, I forgot it was--
no, Santa Barbara.
Santa Barbara, that
little misogynist
who drove around
hitting, killing people.
It was after him, because his
family knew he had problems.
And the police went
to check him out,
but they didn't
go into his room.
Anyway, there are
things that can
be done in that
nexus between people
with violent emotional
and mental problems
and the ease with which
anybody can get a gun.
And it seems like that is an
area where policymakers should
focus as much
attention as they can,
because it seems to be the
area where there's a lot to do.
But the truth of the matter is,
most gun deaths in this country
are suicides, not murders.
And I'm not saying
that's not as serious,
but when people say 30,000 a
year, 2/3 of them are suicides.
And most of the gun deaths are
not mass weapon slaughters.
They are handguns in
individual occurrences,
oftentimes men killing
women in their lives.
So Parkland, that kind of
thing doesn't happen as much,
in terms of body count.
The more serious thing has
to do with individual handgun
shooting incidents.
And I don't know
what can be done.
SPEAKER: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Big fan, since you were a
guest host on ABC "This Week."
JAKE TAPPER: Thanks.
AUDIENCE:
Non-Washington question.
I mean, Washington is
polarized, but the country
is pretty polarized too.
It's probably about
eight states, right,
where you have a chance
of moving the needle.
My brother lives in Missouri,
and he canceled his cable bill
because any time
any election comes,
it's wall to wall political ads.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this seems
like a much harder question.
If I ask myself,
I'm fairly liberal,
even if I was
conservative in the state,
I have no shot of
doing anything.
If everybody is
like me, then what
is the principle that
causes states to shift?
I mean, because if
you don't remove
the polarization in
the people, you're
never going to remove the
polarization in politics.
JAKE TAPPER: Mm-hm.
I don't know.
I'm not an expert on
demographic shifts
or why certain states
become more liberal or more
conservative.
I've seen it happen in my life
as the Northeast has become
decidedly more progressive,
and other parts of the country
have been decidedly
more conservative.
I mean, I'm old enough to
remember Democrats, not just
Democrats, white
Democrats representing
parts of the South.
Mainly, it seems like
the Southern Democrats,
a lot of them are
African American
because they represent
African American districts
redistricted.
And I'm old enough to remember
liberal Republicans, when
Susan Collins was not an
endangered species, when
there were a lot of--
AUDIENCE: There are
none in the House now.
And there were a lot.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah, not
from New England, right?
I mean, you have
Charlie Baker here,
so it's not like
it can't be done.
It can be done.
I don't know why it happens.
I think it just has to do with
one of the things going on
is just people siloing
themselves off from people
with different points of view.
Whether it's cable news,
or news in general,
or websites, or
politicians, we just
seem to be becoming a more
tribal society in terms
of our political beliefs.
Yeah, I mean,
every four years, I
hear about how Missouri
is a purple state,
and I never believe it.
But I have lived long enough to
see purple states go from red
to blue and from blue to red.
I mean, I have lived
long enough to see.
I remember when John Kerry was
trying to get Colorado in 2004.
And I thought he was on
drugs, but now Colorado
is pretty solidly
purple, if not blue.
And amazingly, I can't
even believe it happened.
Barack Obama won Indiana.
I mean, it did happen in 2008.
So different candidates
can win over a populace
based on who they are.
But generally
speaking, I just think
we're becoming more tribal.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious about,
as your career has spanned time
before the internet
was a big thing,
and then now we
have Twitter, and it
feels like everything
has just accelerated.
The news cycle is
faster and faster.
And I'm curious both how
you feel about that and also
how that factored in when you
go back and look at the '50s,
researching that and
then writing about it,
in a world when we didn't
have Twitter and things
weren't happening so quickly.
A great example of that
would be Scott Pruitt.
There's so much news about
Scott Pruitt one week,
and then by Friday, it was
gone, because everybody had
moved on to the next scandal.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah, I mean,
the Scott Pruitt situation,
I can just tell you
as somebody who's
responsible for an hour
of news show every day,
is that President Trump pushes
Scott Pruitt off our deck.
I mean, President Trump--
we'll have, like, a
Scott Pruitt piece.
This has happened now at least
twice, if not three times,
that we had a piece about
Scott Pruitt's five most
recent scandals, and
then President Trump
did or said something,
and we didn't have time
to get to Scott Pruitt.
I mean, so Donald Trump is the
best thing that ever happened
to Scott Pruitt in every way.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it's funny because my
first job in journalism was--
after freelance-- was I worked
for "Washington City Paper."
And then I worked for salon.com.
It was very different
than what it is today.
It was much more--
it was not ideological.
It was just a lot of
different points of view.
It leaned left, because it
was based in San Francisco,
but it was a lot of
different points of view.
And I'll tell you, it was
amazing working for salon.com
in 1999 and 2000, covering
the presidential race,
because at the time--
and some people here might be
too young to remember this--
at the time, newspapers,
other websites,
only updated once a day.
So I would be on
the road with people
from the "LA Times" and "The
New York Times" and "ABC News,"
"Washington Post," whatever,
and something would happen,
and I would write.
I would write a piece on
my laptop and send it in,
and it would post on
Salon within an hour.
And I would scoop
everybody, not because I
was such a great reporter, but
because their websites weren't
going to update until the
next morning at 6:00 AM.
It's crazy.
And then I remember
"The Washington Post"
took this amazing step
that every day at 4:00
they were going
to do one update.
So it was awesome for me,
being on the tip of the spear
of the internet journalism.
Because all these dinosaurs
that I was competing with
didn't realize
what was going on.
Ultimately, they did.
Now the news cycle is crazy.
But when writing the book, the
most you could hope for then
was there was an
afternoon newspaper.
There was "The Washington
Post" in the morning
and "The Washington Star"
in the afternoon in DC.
And I mean, the news,
early on, the evening news
was 15 minutes.
And then they adapted it
to become half an hour.
So it was just like a glacier
moving, the news in that era,
compared to what we
deal with today, where
I'm getting the shakes because
I want to go to my phone
right now and find
what has happened
in the last hour and a half.
What has President Trump done?
What is going on in the world?
Because it changes.
We'll be in the
middle of a show.
I remember one time just in
the last couple of months,
at the top of the
show, I just laid out
all the huge events
that had happened just
in the last 24 hours.
And that was in our A block.
And by our C block,
Hope Hicks had resigned.
And I said, "remember
when I did that commentary
six months ago about all the--
oh, wait.
That was 15 minutes ago."
I mean, that's what it
feels like, this news cycle.
It's just a different era.
By the way, this
has to be it, right?
I mean, we can't get any
more insane than this?
At a certain point,
it would have
to actually be traveling back
in time or something like that.
This is as crazy as it
gets, I would think.
SPEAKER: I think we have time
for about one more question.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I hate to be the last
question with this,
but I can I ask you
about Kellyanne Conway?
JAKE TAPPER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So I think last
weekend she did the rounds
on the Sunday shows.
And it seems like every time she
does one of these Sunday shows,
not only is it a lost
segment, because you don't
get any information out of
her, but the interviewer always
seems to leave it
off frustrated.
JAKE TAPPER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And it just
seems like a waste
of that segment of the show.
So--
JAKE TAPPER: So why do it?
AUDIENCE: Why have her on?
JAKE TAPPER: Why have her on?
So you're not the first
person to ask me this week.
[LAUGHTER]
I did at an event at the 92nd
Street Y Wednesday night,
and Stephen Colbert asked
me the same question.
So you're in good company.
Here's the answer.
First of all, she's a senior
counselor to the president.
So if there is
something going on
and we want answers
to questions,
other than the president,
who hasn't given me
an interview since the
Judge Curiel questions
that I asked him
in June 2016, there
isn't anyone necessarily better.
And Sunday was, I
had questions about--
what was it?
I guess, Michael Cohen.
I forget.
300 scandals ago, but
there was something.
Oh, it was, yeah, Rudy Giuliani
had basically let the cat out
of the bag that the
president had lied.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but it
didn't matter what you asked.
JAKE TAPPER: Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I'm not above
being fact checked.
I appreciate it.
So how do you explain this?
So that's one.
Two, I thought it
was interesting
that the premise of
all my questions,
accurate, but also
a premise was,
the president lies so much.
Why?
Why does the president
tell so many lies?
And her response was, "The
president does many things."
[LAUGHTER]
That's a quote.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAKE TAPPER: "The president
does many things."
Right.
And why aren't you covering
this, this, and this as opposed
to the lies?
So I thought it was interesting.
I thought we were
making progress.
Here we are.
We're making progress.
She's not disputing the
fact that the president
tells lots of lies.
And Roy Blunt, Senate
Republican leadership,
was in the next interview.
Also, "Does it bother you that
the president lies so much?"
was my question.
"It would bother
me a lot more if we
weren't getting so much done."
So I mean, we've made progress.
[LAUGHTER]
They're acknowledging that
the president tells lies.
I felt like a small
victory there.
Third, 63 million
people voted for Trump.
I don't think it's not
worthwhile to have the Trump
point of view represented
on any number of issues,
including hers.
She was trying to explain
what the president meant when
he was on Air Force
One and he said, "No,
he didn't know
about the payment."
You know, whatever.
And then fourth-- and this
one is actually, I think,
the most important to me--
I think there is value in a
news anchor challenging people
in power, even if--
this isn't an Aaron Sorkin
scripted Sunday talk show.
I mean, she's not going
to say, "You're right.
He's a liar.
What am I doing?"
[LAUGHTER]
But I think viewers
can get something out
of feeling
represented, at least.
Why does he tell these lies?
For instance, the
president said that Obama
had tried to get these three
hostages out of North Korea
and failed, but he
was going to do it.
Two of them were taken
hostage during the Trump
administration.
So that would have been a neat
trick, if Obama had actually
anticipated and not
been able to prevent it.
So just to say it, just to
say, it's not true, it's a lie.
I think there is value in that.
That said, it's not as
though it isn't a discussion
that we have every time
we book a Trump guest.
It is a discussion that we have.
What are we going to get?
Why would we do it?
We turn down people.
But anyway, that's my reasoning.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
JAKE TAPPER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thanks so much,
everyone, for coming.
JAKE TAPPER: Thanks for
being here, everyone.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]